In this world...
there are Sorcerers who have
the Magic to undo others' Magic.
Chota!
En!
En! Oh, it's you!
I missed you so much.
Leaving your Partner
locked up in here like this.
Uh, yeah. Sorry Chota.
-He's your Partner?
-As if.
Oh dear, Noi was turned into a lizard man?
That's okay, leave it to me.
This Magic is Transformational, Level C.
Impure.
We'll need dirt from Hell,
the horns of a Devil,
and 666 types of flower seeds.
And most importantly, the entrails
of the person dearest to Noi.
How romantic is that?
Dearest to Noi?
Must be either you or me.
Your entrails are hanging out,
so you do it.
Excuse me.
Mix them all up and put them in a mold.
Fit them together.
Et voilà! A magic doll.
Now eat up,Noi.
Shin, put your hand on Noi's chest
and think about your dearest memory.
Dearest memory?
My dearest memory with Noi...
One time when we first started,
we got beaten up really bad,
and we fell from a cliff together
on the way home.
And finally, a bit of Magic.
Huh...? Senpai?
What happened to you?
Let me fix that right away!
Wait, Noi! Put this on first.